now we've got an update to a story we've
been following cbs news has learned new
information
about widespread drug testing of elite
u.s navy seals in recent days
now this follows our report last month
featuring conversations with current
and former seals who want to remain
anonymous that address very troubling
evidence of drug use in the ranks
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herrich is back she's at the
pentagon with more on the story
catherine good morning to you gail the
cbs news
investigative team has been reporting on
drug use in the seals since 2017
and last week there seemed to be a new
level of accountability
coming from seal leadership
the navy announced last friday it was
returning to normal urinalysis screening
after drug testing was scaled back to
limit exposure to covet 19
during the pandemic cbs news has learned
that before
friday's announcement navy seal
commander rear admiral hugh
howard ordered force-wide testing of his
seal teams
effectively putting the elite operators
on notice
according to an internal email reviewed
by cbs news
sent on may 19 seals were directed to
provide a urine
sample today for those on temporary
assignment or
on official leave the email read you
will provide a urine sample on the day
you return
while random drug testing in the seals
is standard procedure
more than a half dozen active duty and
retired seals
told cbs news that this kind of
force-wide testing is not routine
last month cbs news spoke exclusively
with three current and former seals
who described drug use in the ranks we
agreed to disguise their voices
and hide their identities you have
first-hand
knowledge of deployments
where individuals have been taking
drugs yes yes but i am angry i feel
betrayed
current and former seals told cbs news
they last recalled testing on such a
wide scale
five years ago around 2016 when senior
seal commander jamie sands
read the east coast teams the riot act
how do you decide
that it's okay for you to do drugs two
years after that
dressing down a heavily redacted navy
investigative report
obtained by cbs news showed six members
of seal team 10
tested positive for cocaine i would say
the majority of guys are not doing it
we've got to work hard to find the guys
who are and how they're getting it
around
in response to our questions a navy
spokesperson told cbs news
that maintaining a drug workplace is
critical to warfighting readiness
in keeping with navy policy the
commander directed a force-wide
urinalysis as a prudent measure to
establish a baseline
given covet impacts on program
compliance and the spokesperson
confirmed it was five years ago
the seals had drug testing this broad
anthony
catherine thank you